i'm sure you've all heard about random
college students and young adults
turning a couple of hundred or thousand
dollars into hundreds of thousands or
even millions by investing into momentum
cryptos there was even some guy who
turned eight thousand dollars into 5.7
billion dollars by investing into shiba
inu if you've made life-changing amounts
of money with these altcoins
congratulations that's really quite
awesome but there's someone who's making
a lot more than all of these guys while
taking on far less risk and that's of
course the crypto brokerages
you know what they say when there's a
gold rush you don't want to be digging
for gold you want to be selling the
shovels and that's exactly what sam
bankman did in may of 2019 sam launched
his crypto trading platform fdx and now
he's worth 26.5 billion and did i
mention that he's only 29 years old
forbes claims that sam is actually the
richest person in crypto satoshi
nakamoto is of course richer but if we
just look at known figures forbes is
probably right so here's the story of
sam bankman and how he became the
richest known crypto figure
taking a look back sam was born on march
6 1992 in stanford california both of
his parents were law professors at
stanford so i think it's safe to assume
that sam had a well-off childhood he
spent a lot of free time reading harry
potter and watching the san francisco
giants as for school he attended a small
private school in the bay area before
scoring a spot at mit where he majored
in physics physics is one of the hardest
majors to complete if not the hardest
and sam was doing it at mit so you would
think that college consumed all of his
time but sam says that he was able to
half-ass his way through it
apparently he spent most of his time
playing video games including starcraft
and league of legends as opposed to
studying so we're probably looking at a
child prodigy
initially sam was looking to become a
physics professor similar to his parents
but as he developed a strong interest in
ethics and morality he slowly strayed
away from this path
sam was especially interested in
effective altruism and utilitarianism
instead of donating money to trendy
causes sam believes that one should
donate money to causes that will
objectively do the most good for example
causes that save the most amount of
lives or create the most amount of
income per dollar donated in order to
make such an impact though sam knew that
he needed big money and he simply wasn't
going to get there by being a professor
so instead of pursuing higher level
degrees sam took on a lucrative finance
job at a quantitative firm called the
jane street capital
unlike other crypto billionaires sam
never really cared about crypto and he
wasn't an early adopter by any means in
fact crypto didn't catch his attention
until 2017 when bitcoin was running from
a few thousand dollars to twenty
thousand dollars
even then he didn't really care about
the fundamentals of bitcoin or what it
stood for he wasn't interested in
bitcoin's promise of being an inflation
hedge or its decentralized nature what
he was interested in though was
bitcoin's inefficient markets
one day sam noticed that you could buy
bitcoin in the us and sell it on
secondary markets for a substantially
larger amount and that's how it all
started sam says quote i got involved in
crypto without any idea what crypto was
it just seemed like there was a lot of
good trading to do something else that
attracted sam to crypto was the lack of
regulation
opening up a traditional trading firm
requires a lot of licenses and help from
lawyers which is not cheap
but with crypto basically anyone can
open a trading firm especially if it
isn't based in the us sam wasn't the
only one trying to leverage this
opportunity though
exploiting this price difference to make
profits is actually an established form
of trading called arbitrage trading
anyway sam would end up quitting his job
and he would start an arbitrage crypto
trading firm called alameda research in
october of 2017.
initially it was just him and a couple
of recent college graduates but despite
the rookie nature of their startup it
didn't take long for them to raise a lot
of money given sam's experience working
on wall street he was able to brand
himself as the wall street professional
that was offering crypto trading
services combine this with the fact that
the rest of wall street didn't want to
associate with crypto at least not
publicly and the extreme fomo associated
with the 2017 bull run sam was able to
raise millions within a few months by
january of 2018 sam was trading 25
million worth of bitcoin per day but
this was the peak of the bitcoin bull
run and things only went downhill from
there sam wasn't worried about the hype
dying off though as he had sensed a much
larger opportunity as he was trading
millions of dollars per day he noticed
that existing crypto brokerages were
trash when it came to trading the
popular crypto brokerages like coinbase
had spent all of their effort on making
crypto purchases as seamless as possible
for individual investors and while they
were phenomenal at this they weren't
very good at handling high-speed trade
volume from traders
so sam decided to create his own crypto
brokerage that would be tailored towards
crypto traders
over the next several months sam became
more involved with the crypto community
by attending various crypto conferences
and meeting with various crypto
investors and traders from around the
world after attending a crypto
conference in macau sam would actually
choose to move to hong kong and this is
where he would launch fdx sam took
profits from alameda and worked with a
couple of venture capital firms to raise
a total of 8 million dollars which he
would use to develop fdx throughout the
beginning of 2019.
with 8 million dollars and all of his
experience sam was able to develop the
perfect platform for traders and he
eagerly launched fdx in may of 2019 but
the sam's disappointment the launch of
fdx was nothing like the launch of
alameda alameda was launched during the
peak of the bull run when many investors
were desperate to get into crypto but by
may of 2019 bitcoin had crashed 80 and
ethereum had crashed 94
there was no hype left and many thought
that crypto was dead forever it was
basically just the hodlers and
backholders left and these guys had no
interest in trading sam even hired a
dozen salesmen to stand around at
weebrook locations to try to convince
traders to give fdx a shot but still no
one was interested so sam had to think
outside of the box
bitcoin no longer had hype so he
couldn't rely on momentum traders who
rode the wave up and down but something
that bitcoin still very much had was
volatility so sam decided to lean in on
the volatility by introducing crypto
derivatives
if you're not familiar with the
derivatives it's basically just
leveraged trading through the use of
options futures and margin
now i cannot understate how dangerous
these are trading derivatives on stocks
itself is super dangerous and you could
argue that crypto itself is more
dangerous than stock derivatives so when
you're trading derivatives on crypto
you're basically trading derivatives of
derivatives to make things even worse
there's very little regulation in crypto
trading so the leverage you can take is
sky high
on stocks you'd be hard-pressed to find
1x leverage without using options
meanwhile ftx offers up to 20x leverage
this means that with 10 000 in cash you
can control 200 000 worth of bitcoin if
bitcoin rises just five percent you
double your money but the thing that
people forget is that if bitcoin just
drops five percent you lose everything
i don't think i need to explain why this
is extremely dangerous
ideally sam was looking to attract
professional traders who knew the risk
and had experience with leverage
but naturally he ended up attracting a
large number of retail gamblers looking
for a moonshot opportunity nonetheless
this was extremely lucrative by may of
2020 ftx had grown to 200 000 users with
daily trading volume of 1 billion
dollars and since then things have just
gone to the moon as of october ftx
boasted a total of 2 million users with
a daily trading volume of 11.5 billion
dollars to put that in perspective
coinbase has 68 million users or 34
times fdx yet they only average about 5
billion per day in volume which works
out to about 74 dollars per person per
day meanwhile ftx averages 5 750 per
person per day
ftx only charges a fee of 0.005 to 0.07
per transaction but with 11.5 billion
worth of trading volume per day we're
talking about somewhere between half a
million to 8 million dollars per day if
we estimate in the middle and call it
four million dollars we're looking at
about 1.5 billion in revenue per year
and given that the business has very
little overhead forbes estimates that
their profit margin is about 50
aside from crypto derivatives fdx has
also introduced tokens of popular stocks
like apple this allows investors from
underprivileged areas to safely
participate in the american stock market
fdx also introduced their own token
which now accounts for a large portion
of sam's wealth given all of this
exposure to crypto you would think that
sam is a massive believer in crypto but
this is actually not the case
now it's not like sam is calling for
bitcoin to go to zero but he's also not
calling for it to go to the moon he
didn't enter the crypto markets based on
conviction he entered based on
opportunity and that's the only reason
he's still there at this point he's just
hoping that crypto survives long enough
for him to give away all his wealth as
the only thing sam has conviction in is
giving away all his money if that's
through crypto and ftx great but if
crypto goes down and something else
emerges he's just as fine about
switching to that instead
right now he's reinvesting all the
profits back into the business given
that the company is only 2.5 years old
but even through that he's managed to
donate 25 million dollars sam hopes that
by riding out the crypto wave and
holding off to sell he can donate over
900 times that or about 22.5 billion now
i don't want to take away from his
generosity but i do think it should be
noted that sam's donations so far
haven't necessarily been as altruistic
as he originally promised last year sam
donated 5.2 million dollars to joe
biden's campaign which made him the
second largest individual donor only
beaten out by michael bloomberg and i
think we can all agree that political
donations are some of the least
effective donations when it comes to
altruistic motives so hopefully sam does
eventually focus on the altruistic
avenues that he originally described but
only time will tell
in the meantime that's how sam bankman
went from zero to 26.5 billion dollars
in just four years do you guys believe
that sam will actually follow through
and donate all his money and if so do
you think his donations will actually be
as altruistic as he describes comment
that down below
also drop a like if you wish you could
make 26.5 billion dollars in four years
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one